it's hard enough to make sense about
small amounts of data much less big data
there's so many problems with it each of
them is like a speed bump and I really
want to lower some of those speed bumps
and make Italy easier but at the same
time if you lower them too much you get
a lot of people that are making false
conclusions misunderstanding and miss
applying data you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
us today I'm talking with veteran
Microsoft researcher dr. Stephen trekker
about data visualization his advice for
aspiring research scientists the long
slow work of big breakthroughs and why
stand-up comedy is an important skill
for computer scientists that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast tell me a little bit
what your background is and how you
actually planted long and twisty paths I
actually started out as a neuroscientist
I did my undergraduate work at
neurosciences and I was really inspired
as a kid by the sort of bionic man and
prosthetics and and and trying to hook
up devices to the brain and I got into
robotics from that and so there was from
neurosciences to robotics was a very
logical progression then I mean maybe
this like going back too far but at the
time my advisor didn't get tenure so I
left and I switched over to a different
group that was doing computer graphics
because computer graphics and robotics
are really similar and so I did computer
graphics that's what I did by PhD and
and I came out to Microsoft 22 years ago
where there was a group that was looking
at graphical environments for social
communication did that for a number of
years and you know I was hoping that it
was going to be the new media form that
this was going to be the new way to
communicate the new way to tell stories
and yet it got to be very much sort of
hit driven iterative kind of like what
Hollywood is here's the next version of
no tomb raider a three
you know Grand Theft Auto 5 you see this
sort of iteration they're not taking
risks so I got a little bit more
interested in sort of just organizing
and collecting of media so I did a lot
of things with photos and photo
collections and tagging and organizing
photo collections partly because in some
ways this was a problem that we were
having at home well from organizing
collecting media it's not a big leap to
go to large collections of things and
large data and understanding data and
communicating with that data and I've
been doing that for the last eight years
or so so give the listeners an elevator
pitch of what you do at Microsoft well
yes I'm in Microsoft Research and I
focus on data visualization which is
trying to understand complex data and
communicate insights about that data to
other semantic actions on it and
building tools so people can in turn
understand that data themselves and so
less data analysis more building tools
so that other people can understand and
communicate that data you're building
tools for data analysis exactly yes so I
mean there there are a lot of people
that get hired on as a data analyst and
then they might be you know using
whether it's programming or existing
tools to do that and they have good
skills in that but I'm also really
interested in kind of reaching directly
to the public I think again I think
about myself as a communicator even more
than an analyzer
when you say building tools my mind goes
directly to the product groups but
you're in Microsoft research where on
the spectrum of building alright you
know I've been in Microsoft research for
22 years and I've gone back and forth in
that spectrum and I think that's part of
why someone might go to Microsoft
research as opposed to going to an
academic department in Microsoft
research we're very bottom-up driven so
we come up with new ideas that aren't
necessarily what the customers are
asking for it can be very problematic if
you just ask customers what they want I
don't know if you've heard these old
stories about how you drive cars their
very first focus groups on driving a car
were reins
where you pull on one side or the other
because that's what people were
accustomed to so you can't necessarily
asking
people for solutions to their problems
and I look at research to a certain
extent as trying to break out of
innovators dilemma where we're trying to
come up with new ideas from the bottom
up and sometimes they go into products
and sometimes they go in academic papers
and sometimes they just go nowhere and
we drop them
[Music]
some people say that one reason
technology is advancing so quickly
exponentially if if that's where we go
with it is that we're using tools now
that are better than the tools before
and so each year we use leading to the
question what tools are are you actually
using to do your work what do you find
yourself like you have a technological
tool belt when you pull out the most to
do the work you like to do on like with
sand dance what did you make that way
sand ants is built on top of JavaScript
and we use WebGL which is the 3d
graphics library for doing on a webpage
so this is interesting it's the tools
that we use to build that our text
editors and compilers they're not that
different than what I was doing 25 years
ago so that's kind of funny when you
look at that but my tool usage has not
changed that much that being said we are
standing on the shoulders of all these
things I don't start from scratch each
time I actually really like the
open-source movement and that we are you
know sand ants and most of the power bi
custom visuals are available as open
source projects we actually got the
permission to open source it and it's
it's fine to go ahead and do that I
think is great because then we are all
standing on everybody else's shoulders
and then you're combining them in
different ways I think that is a huge
change right and I remember back in the
day intellectual property IP being this
big thing and its proprietary we're not
gonna let anyone peek into kimono and
and it's like nobody's thinking that
does feel like that and I think it's
great because I can get you know people
out of school and they could be oh yeah
I can do this sort of thing instead of
saying well when you come you can spend
about you know three courses a year or
learning how to do this thing before you
can actually make any boundaries and now
I say well here's this library out there
that we can use this because it's really
been in pre-approved that we could use
it and we can put this with this library
we'll get something new which is amazing
[Music]
what advice would you give aspiring
researchers like what knowledge face or
skill sets do you think they need the
way I look at that is I don't want
everybody to be a computer scientist I
look at at coding as sort of one of the
new tools to have so I think learning
code is gonna be fundamentally important
for any job that you have whether you're
going to be someone writing software or
a lawyer or so so that there's that
there's also the style of algorithmic
thinking all of those things are
important certainly understanding data
is a big challenge and it's not
challenge that's going away so having
some backgrounds and you know
programming enough to be able to do the
data statistics machine learning is hot
right now and there might be it over
hype maybe not I mean this is there
we're seeing results so those knowledge
are really important I guess something
we haven't discussed that and they were
discussed before is I really look at
this computer as a tool that augments
our abilities and I think one of the
things that we do bring it that it is
hard to duplicate right now is the
creativity I like to see people with
have a design sense or aesthetic you
know can do things creatively and
aesthetically in addition to technically
I think it's really important for
someone have the skills to talk about
what they're doing why it's important
and make that accessible for a wide
audience has not been a problem for
computer science people before not at
all we have periodically from MSR
something called tech fest where we show
the rest of the company of things we're
working on and that's always fun because
you're you're you're up there talking
about this stuff some people that still
are like oh my god you this is your you
Killians not you you're not really
appealing to everybody here but if you
can explain your things in a way that
gets people excited about it and pulls
them in that that helps everybody so as
much as the the technical abilities I
think this this communicate occasion is
as important you know I have an in
research so I go to conferences and I
speak in these conferences a skill
that's really important there that
surprising is stand-up comedy oh my gosh
yes improv and to be able to take a
question
understand that question to respond to
it let's move on to data to use a
metaphor we're kind of swimming in it
and it seems like the problem now is
more about how we make sense of it how
we find what we're looking for and what
we make of it once we find it so what's
going on your world that you'd contend
is helping us are you getting that's a
huge question and it's hard enough to
make sense about small amounts of data
much less big data I find that it's it's
really hard to make sense of data you
need a lot of skills and a lot of sort
of experience and background and
statistics and and programming and
shaping that data there's so many
problems with it and each of them is
like a speed bump and I really want to
lower some of those speed bumps and make
Italy easier but at the same time if you
lower them too much you get a lot of
people that making false conclusions not
even talking about fake news but but
just sort of misunderstanding and miss
applying data so let me make that
concrete from a research perspective
because you're a researcher what kinds
of things are you doing because I I love
what you're saying and I want that for
me well I you know one thing that we've
done in my group particularly is worked
on a research project that was showing
data in I we call it unit visualization
where you show every piece of data
organized in different ways to show
different conclusions and that was great
as a research project you give talks but
we also ship that in power bi as a
custom visual so anybody actually you
can go to a website right now and you
can try it without you know for free for
just trying these ideas load your own
data set in there and experiment with
that and look at these things in examine
your data in different ways
your professionally interested in how
people communicate with data yes I
definitely am unpack that now one of the
things I find about a lot of the
academics that I work with or a lot of
researchers that they are fairly good
communicators at their own audience and
they're not very good communicators they
don't necessarily understand what people
don't understand them
you know how could they not get this and
part of I think effective communication
is to try to put this in in ways that
they invite like visualizations they can
see it they can ask questions about it
and you haven't done a little bit of a
dialogue about it so okay I think that's
one element is is understanding where
people don't communicate I don't
understand our visual systems are highly
developed and we can see patterns often
times we can see patterns when they're
not there but we can start seeing the
relationships and where again we're
wired that way so if we can hook into
that and and pique their interest and
and start having them understand that
that's kind of one of what I've been
focusing on all right no that's a it's
it's an interesting trying to do this in
a podcast is very difficult cuz this is
inherently visual right there are
auditory of visualizations and we can do
that as well but again so much of our
brain is devoted to understanding visual
phenomenon we talked about the current
tension between that swirls around deep
neural network so this is a topic that a
lot of people don't really understand
and I don't necessarily think we have to
unpack it here but algorithms have
become so complex that people can't even
understand them let alone explain them
and you mentioned a recent ruling in the
EU that's right that says you can't make
a decision with an algorithm that a
human can't explain I think there's a
requirement to explain those decisions
okay so you can make a decision but you
better be able to explain exactly and
you think how important that is if
you're gonna be per rolling someone or
hiring someone or firing someone and you
don't want to say well viewers said to
fire you and so we're firing you let's
back up let's back up is that happening
uh there's parole this has been a big
argument recently about sort of
algorithmic systems for recidivism
you know how likely is it for someone to
to really run again and they're trained
on data and of course the data might
contain biases in it might be trained on
a population that's not that not the
same problem oh my gosh that is such a
huge thing that is I mean on so many
levels yes exactly and you know machine
learning to me is is amazing because we
you know we've had huge strides in
progress over the last decade about
doing things like understanding voice
and and objects and maybe we'll have
intelligent guard in cars but the same
time a lot of it really is just looking
at statistical relationships between
input and outputs and we don't really
know what's going on inside those
relationships and sometimes there might
be get erroneous data that leads into it
or some small problems and I actually
see a visualization playing an important
role in this it's very very hard to
visualize these models but maybe to try
to understand where they're working and
where they're not working or give people
an idea or perhaps we can explain most
of the cases by a simpler more visual
model and then sometimes we can't
explain the rest and so what do we do
when the discrepancies but III think
this is one of these big areas right now
on big challenges you talk about big
areas and challenges in my mind I kind
of envision researchers in their labs
working for the next big breakthrough is
that what you guys are doing on one hand
yes we all want breakthroughs you always
want the big thing but I look at a lot
of the the big things now and like
Facebook Facebook's like the seventh or
eighth iteration of a period of you know
friend network Twitter you know that was
like instant messaging and your email
you have all of these things that are
huge now there aren't exactly
breakthroughs but they're they're big
because the time was right the the
circumstances are right they had the
right sauce whatever it was that and the
technology that enabled it was right
that's right exactly and you you look at
the iPad you know there didn't pen
computing going on since the mid 80s so
these things have happened over and over
and over again and sometimes the time is
right you know so what are those big
breakthroughs we often don't know what
those breakthroughs are until you know
hindsight you know like that was a
breakthrough but I didn't call it that
when I was making that's right and and I
think there is a rush toward some of
these breakthroughs whether it's with
augmented reality there's a lot of
interest in that right now or
self-driving cars a lot of interest in
that yeah I think we all kind of
want that Oh things were like this
before and I've done something to make
it fundamentally different you know
academic research and research in
general it's not usually like that it's
usually very very incremental and
careful and there's this balance between
that careful science and the oh my god
we made something big you know we've got
this rush to a new startup and that's
really exciting and I think you kind of
want a little bit of the energy from
both of those to go together I love love
love how you said that because it's hard
work and it's slow work and it's rarely
the Big Bang the metaphor I usually like
is is standing on the beach when the
waves are coming in if you just stand
there and you watch any single wave it's
only a little bit further than the last
wave but you're standing away at the top
looking down and looking at this over
several hours like oh my god I was down
there before and now it's way up here
called the tide not a wave exactly and
and when you are standing on that beach
amongst doing that work it's very
incremental you're just trying to get
past those last little little wavelets
yeah and then again when you step back
you go home how this is it and then you
have to step back and examine Oh Harry's
about to be flooded we should do
something about that
on the spectrum of let's just say
Microsoft cuz that's what we're talking
about but you've got your research
people that are the out there in five
years you got your product people that
are right now and then you got your end
consumers and so that spectrum of how
you contribute to both the company and
then the world the concentric circles
out how do you envision that I mean how
do you internalize that what you do how
does it make a difference yeah I mean it
changes a different time so sometimes
that's you shoot for that outside circle
the world but along the way you figure
out like here's a stepping stone that I
can publish and here's the end so I'll
at least get this other audience of
people working on it and maybe here's a
product and I might be able to impact
and they'll reach a different audience I
mean you know that's sort of leading
there so sometimes it's like I've got
this directed thing and I'll do those
step stones a long way other times it's
it's almost the reverse it's sort of
like someone has come up with this thing
that they really want you you can give
them you know beyond that solution and
and it was just the sort of short term
that takes you off in a new direction
that you didn't know before I got into
that too the photo management stuff
partly because talking cuz I had that
problem
other people were drawing you were tall
and we were seeing that and this was
before iPhoto and you before there were
any of those let's focus on this and we
did this for a good five six years and
that led to a whole flowering of
different areas but that really was in
response to some short-term problems
that was thinking I think this is big
and don't you think sometimes that's how
a lot of big solutions started out as
accidents like I think I'm gonna test
for this and it ever sound like that
medicine worked for that instead yeah in
that field and all the other things in
fact I think it was in Hamming storing a
word acceptance speech he talks about
how that was almost the kiss of death
because everybody then was expecting
just big projects from him and therefore
those thousand little tiny projects
didn't have a chance for any of them to
bloom into something else so starting
with this idea it's gonna be big can be
deadly
so you need to have this mix of you
knows bigger things that if people are
clobbering on
no flowers living so it's really hard to
say what circle are you aiming at right
now all right I mean it's a moon shot
and sometimes it's like I'm just gonna
do but you know that's right because
maybe I'll eat somewhere else it's
really something big unexpectedly Steven
Drucker thanks for coming in and sharing
your passion and your stories in your
projects and everything else it's been
my pleasure to learn more about dr.
Steven Drucker's work and data
visualization and other great things
going on in Microsoft Research visit
microsoft.com
[Music]